welcome back so now we're actually going
to start coding up real examples in
MATLAB seeing if they're controllable
designing controllers to stabilize the
dynamic so this should be really fun and
really powerful ok we did a lot of math
to understand why and when and how to
control things but now the rubbers are
going to hit the road and we're actually
going to see how easy it is to really
control a system in MATLAB ok
so one of the systems I really like to
work with is imagine that I have an
inverted pendulum but that inverted
pendulum is sitting on top of a cart
okay and so I'm going to have my
inverted pendulum but now that pendulum
is on a cart and I can move that cart
around
so for some reason this has only felt
much more physical to me than just you
know having a pendulum with some torque
control on the bottom that seems too
easy this is a little more interesting
right I have some cart and I can move
that cart around and I'm trying to
stabilize this inverted pendulum okay so
let's think about what numbers we need
well first of all we need to define the
state of the system okay and so the
state of the system is given by the
position of this cart so we're going to
call that X and the angle of this
pendulum arm we're going to call that
theta so our kind of high dimensional
dynamical system States I'm going to
change it up and I'm going to call it a
vector Y so this state Y dot and maybe
I'm not going to call it like so that'll
be confusing with the output measure
mental to keep it X the vector of states
I'm going to say is this position script
X it's the loss of the script X dot
theta and theta dot okay and so this is
a two degree of freedom system there's
two degrees of freedom X and theta the
position of the cart and the angle of
the pendulum and because it's two
degrees of freedom
with Newton's second law I get four
coupled OD E's okay so I essentially
have some D DT of x equals some
nonlinear function of that vector X so
this is for nonlinear row equations I'm
not going to bore you with the details
of how to actually derive these but you
could use something like Euler Lagrange
equation or Hamilton's equations and you
could get these coupled first order
nonlinear oh jeez okay so this is an
honest-to-goodness nonlinear problem but
we can linearize the system and just
intuitively we know that there are a
couple of key fixed points okay so the
fixed point of the system fixed points
we're going to have a fixed point
corresponding to the pendulum down
position so what we know has to happen
is theta has to equal either zero for
the pendulum down or pi for the pendulum
up theta dot has to equal zero X dot has
to equal zero and if I wrote down all of
these equations you'd see that none of
these rates of change actually depend on
X itself and so X is a free variable and
that kind of makes sense right it
doesn't matter if this thing is here or
here or here if I have the the pendulum
up or down and there's no velocities
it's a fixed point so I've got two basic
fixed points corresponding to let's say
the theta equals zero case is the
pendulum down with the cart fixed and
the theta equals PI is going to be the
pendulum up with the cart fixed okay and
so if you had the Euler Lagrange
equations and you had these fixed points
you could compute the Jacobian and you
can essentially get you know so through
D F
DX evaluated at a fixed point you could
get a linear system of equations X dot
equals ax plus B u ok and now I haven't
told you what what u is this is a super
important so you the control input for
this system what we're going to get to
control we're going to say that that u
equals a force on the cart in the X
direction okay and this is actually very
reasonable what I can do is I could have
like a motor on one of these wheels and
I can have some controller so that I
could if I specified I want you know
twice the force I could give it twice
the voltage and make this thing move
okay so this is actually very realistic
you could build a cart that would hold
this pendulum and drive it around and
you could actuate with force okay and so
now what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to fire up MATLAB and show you
I've already cooked up all of these
examples so I have this nice function so
in MATLAB right I build these right hand
side functions this is my nonlinear OTE
it's called cart pend the cart pendulum
system and it gives me the time
derivative given the state so here it's
called Y that's why I wanted to call it
Y sometimes in MATLAB you call you
states Y that's just kind of MATLAB
convention and a couple of other numbers
I just have a bunch of parameters out
here so I say that this little mass has
mass little m the cart has mass big m
this inverted pendulum has a length L we
know that gravity pulls down and then
there's D which is essentially some
damping term okay so in these equations
there could be some friction
I believe I mean the damping to be as
opposing the X dot okay so it's the
damping on the cart maybe this cart has
action and I'm assuming the pendulum has
a lot less friction and then finally I
have this u so if I was going to apply a
force you can derive oiler LeGrande or
Hamilton's with some four six applied
and I'm not going to bore you with all
the details there's going to be a link
to this on youtube so you can download
this code and read through it yourself
but the right-hand side these dynamics
are pretty nasty okay this actually
takes a long time to derive by hand on
pencil and paper for the system this is
the most time-consuming part of this
whole demo is actually getting this
right-hand side vector vector field
right but I'm not going to bore you with
the details you can see like if I go on
and on it's a pretty long nasty
expression okay and the input the force
enters in the X dot and the theta dot
equations when you go through Euler
Lagrangian Oh big deal
it's just a nonlinear right-hand side
and this is relatively easy to simulate
the system with or without forcing in
MATLAB so I'm going to go up to this
function called sim cart pen and all I
do is I specify some parameters so I say
this is mass one this is mass five
length this to gravity is normal and
there's some moderate dissipation on the
cart and in MATLAB I can integrate
vector field using OD 45 so I can
integrate this if I set up some time
span so I want I want to integrate from
zero to time ten with this initial
condition so again this initial
condition means X is zero X dot is zero
theta is PI so it's up and state a dot
is point five so it starts in the up
position but it's moving in the to the
right I think or you know in the
positive theta direction maybe it's so
left but anyway then I go through and I
write this OD e45 I tell it that I want
to integrate XY dot equals this function
of Y and I'm going to lock in these
parameters and there's zero control so
for right now we're just going to
simulate this thing in
the physics with no forcing okay
and down here at the bottom I have a
function I written called draw cart
penned and so essentially it just plots
a movie of the pendulum and again you
can download this and see what I did
so let's actually try to run this sim
cart penned okay so this runs and you
can see this is basically what you
expect to happen you let this thing go
and it's going to just swing and swing
and swing and eventually if I integrated
it for longer it would come to rest
maybe I'll just show you that because
it's pretty easy I'll integrate it for a
little bit longer okay it's going to go
and it's just going to keep swinging and
swinging and swinging and eventually
frictional kick in and it'll kind of
come to rest okay
and it's only stuck here because I
stopped integrating so that's the system
we're going to control okay we're in a
great shape to actually control this
system so what we're going to do we know
the fixed points I you know offline I
computed this Jacobian matrix that was
ugly and kind of a mess and I plugged in
these fixed points so I have linearized
equations about the pendulum up
condition and I have linearized
conditions about the pendulum down
condition and so what we're going to do
is we're going to simulate we're going
to design controllers based on those
linearization and then apply them to the
full honest-to-goodness nonlinear system
okay so the first thing we need to do is
get this Jacobian then we plug in the
fixed points and either the pendulum up
or pendulum down condition to get this
linear system and then the first thing
we need to do is check and see is this
controllable okay so that's what we're
going to do now I have this code here
called pull place cart penned okay and
what I've done here is offline I've
essentially cooked up the a matrix and
the B matrix for this linearized system
of equation
and because the up linearization and the
down linearization shares so much in
common I decided to have this little
switch where if the pendulum is up the
switch is 1 and if the pendulum is down
the switch is negative 1 and so
essentially this is the linearized
matrix the a matrix for both conditions
and if I want to go for pendulum up to
pendulum down I just switch this s this
s and this s to negative values okay so
this is the a matrix and the B matrix
now all I want to do at this point is
first of all I'm going to run this code
so I'm going to run my I'm going to run
pull place carp end so it's going to
load the a matrix and the B matrix oh I
think that ran the whole thing so I'm
going to load my a matrix and I'm going
to look at I of a so these are the
eigenvalues of my a matrix in the
pendulum up condition and notice that
one of these eigenvalues is unstable so
that thing is eventually if it's if it's
epsilon off of vertical it's going to
accelerate away now what's really
important is I want to know what is a
and B controllable okay so this was
something we've been working up for up
towards and it should be really easy to
test now so I'm going to try first of
all CPR B of a comma B this will give me
that controllability matrix it's a big
matrix I'm just going to hit enter
you'll see right it's a big matrix it's
a 4 by 4 matrix so if I look at the rank
of this CTR B matrix if this rank is 4
my system is controllable if this rank
is not for the system is not
controllable okay so with this a matrix
and this B matrix corresponding to force
in the x-direction of the cart because
the rank of my controllability matrix is
4
I can span all of my state space with
this controllability subspace and that
means that I can actually develop a
controller to control the system so
what's coming next this will be in the
next video
we know it's controllable and so what
that means is that I can cook up some
control law u equals minus KX so that
the closed-loop system is X dot equals a
minus BK X and I can develop I can
design K so that the eigenvalues of this
are anywhere I want them to be so what
I'm going to do next is I'm going to
specify I want stable eigenvalues I want
to move these eigenvalues into the
stable the stable left half plane so we
had that one unstable eigenvalue I'm
going to move it into the stable left
half plane with some proportional
feedback of X and just to remember what
this diagram looks like we have our
system in this case the cart pendulum
we're going to measure the full state X
we're going to feed it back so U is
going to be minus KX
okay so we're literally going to say u
equals minus this matrix K times the
measurements of X we're going to measure
everything and that's going to stabilize
the system to have these eigenvalues so
that's what we're going to do next we're
going to use the place command in MATLAB
to place these eigen values and design
this matrix K then we're going to
develop an optimal eigen value placement
using the linear quadratic regulator or
lqr control so that's coming up next